we've got another kind of performance
for you that was really really top top
top notch acclaim singer and songwriter
Andre Abu Kelly is using his powerful
voice to spread a message of hope during
this very challenging difficult painful
time beau Shelly performed Amazing Grace
and other spiritual songs yesterday and
what he called an Easter prayer at the
Duomo that's the historic Cathedral the
Italian city of Milan let's listen
[Music]
who
[Music]
the Italian tenor sang without an
audience in accordance with the
government regulations for social
distancing more than 26 million people
worldwide have watched that performance
on YouTube that number is actually now
close to three point three and a half
million Andre oh boo Kelly joins us now
from his home for an interview that
you'll see only on CBS this morning
there he is Andre abou Kelly first thank
you thank you thank you good morning
good luck to everybody morning you were
Jess I need can you hear me
okay I can hear you go ahead you were
just what we needed on an Easter Sunday
aundrea just what we needed
well I hope so because the the music can
help a lot I think in my experience I
can say that music is very important for
the fullest ole you said aundrea before
you did the before you sang for us you
said this was not a concert that you
were offering a prayer what did you mean
by that you said you wanted to give the
earth a big hug while we were going
through this very difficult time and we
were returning the hug back to you but
what was your thinking about offering a
prayer to us well I I said when I
received this invitation from the mayor
of Milan I said okay I'm very happy to
come and this the singing will be not an
exhibition will be not a concert but it
will be only a prayer because in this
moment the the only important thing is
to pray you know there
to resolve as soon as possible this
incredible problem yeah Italy has been
very hard hit as you know I'm wondering
how you were how you and your family are
dealing with that and what are your
thoughts about your country this morning
[Music]
well if you have to stay all the day in
the house the day really becomes very
long but I try yes first of all I try to
speak with my sons
I read I play I sing and I try to have
beautiful moments with my wife so I need
my family yes yes I think that's what
we're all doing Andre and I'm wondering
what it was like for you it was really
beautiful number one to see you walk out
to the microphone to sing amazing grace
what was it like to you to sing with no
audience how did that feel for you on
the other side well my program my
problem was not done half the audience
because when I when I sing at home I'm
used to be to sing without the audience
but the situation was really strange
because painful because you singing I
thought to the people that yesterday
would have been in the church and
instead of they had to stay at home so
suffering many of many of them suffering
so my thoughts were for for them what
advice do you have for people who are
struggling during this time you're so
right that music is a very healing thing
but it's still a very painful time what
what is your message of hope for people
who are struggling this is very
difficult for all of us
well I I think I am an optimist and the
most important thing is don't lose the
hope and to to be convinced that very
soon everything will be over you still
feel you still feel optimistic that it
will be over soon you feel that yes
absolutely all right Andre over celli
sending you a virtual hug thank you so
much you were perfection on an Easter
Sunday thank you thank you very much
it's a pleasure thank you always good to
see you
Andrea Bocelli and you heard his
translator with him talking to us from
Milan